yes he who is a full-stack developer for
the platform that we will show you and
tell you about the power that is have to
analyze your own data and beyond in
India we represented by four people
primarily I would like to introduce
resume he's a director he's genuine from
genuine machine learning I said brought
him separately and apart apart is a
research intern with us and should
regime should be detailed so our
research interns working with us for
quite some time now
so all our team are a plea managed and
very effectively managed by our CEO area
Trotsky who is getting us we have some
collaborations by virtue of our birth or
the 2017 we are been trying to bring in
a project based education in the domain
of bioinformatics and trying to extend
our knowledge that has been gained for a
decade of research on the various
aspects of bioinformatics and as result
we have like we have entered into
collaborative understanding in many of
the universities across the world
chiefly University of Nebraska Medical
Center Tulane University L BRL Loyola
Georgetown and India we have recently
entered into a collaboration with
Hamidah University a Bennett University
and so on so our vision and mission
between of mine body kind of matched and
with mine with biofuels therefore we
have entered into a collaboration with
them I mean I would really like to thank
very effective and very knowledgeable
team of biofuels who has taken sincere
effort to make these collaboration
effective and we would like to work with
them in the future to make our efforts
more sustainable and also much more
productive and to provide the right kind
of service
and collaborations collaborative factors
for the people who are to belong to
biofuels and beyond so as a result of
this collaboration we'd like to bring in
front of you a program which we say as
biology as a data science so this is the
joint program between biofuels and by in
biotech the 19th century was all about
describing the biological events that
occurred around human visible to the
naked eye in the 20th century humans
attempted to to deeper in each of these
biological events to understand the
mechanisms at the cellular and the sub
cellular level and finally in the
present era of 21st century below it
belongs to the heights who put
experiment water high troop of
experiments they are mostly automated
and measure the functions accelerator
and subsequent level as a result
producing a huge amount of data giving
birth to a concept which is called big
data looking back in history as to how
we got here now it all started with the
discovery of double helix of DNA by
Watson and great rosalind Franklin and
Morrisville entities the quest continued
and in 1990 an optimistic project was
envisaged to sequence the human genome
the project required a hoping amount of
3.1 billion of US dollar and spanned for
almost 13 years the project also paved
the way for discovery of new
computational techniques and therefore
aluminium made its entry and Illumina
machine made its entry and this provided
the precision and lesser sequencing
costs now in 2018 we have thousands of
genome instead of a single genome
for again giving birth the concept of
you know a lot of amount of data which
needs to be understood they need to be
analyzed
they need to be curated and they need to
be provided meaning to so NGS also
change the perspective of how a
clinician looked at a clinical
phenomenon now what a clinician can see
as a clinical data are actually governed
by and characterized by the genomics
proteomics
transcriptomics epigenetics and
microbiome now essays and experiments in
the public domain ladle to the
accumulation of a huge amount of data
which can be otherwise said as data
explosion according to our 2017 white
paper of Stanford University of School
of Medicine by 2020 there will be two
three one for exabytes of data
specifically in the healthcare domain
and as you can see one x-fi equals to
several million megabytes and this
staggering book growth is by almost 48
percent now here comes the entry of us a
cumulative understanding on these data
deluge let us develop a consolidated set
of tools which would address the need of
data analysis in a multitude of domains
we would like to introduce to you our
flagship product which is known as
server dot T - 500 you can also call in
the T by of black or the T by a platform
is a large collection of algorithms
which in various domains like NGS mass
spectroscopy and most importantly
machine learning particularly data
Association and data mining this
platform gives a biologist the power of
another
she is all her own data effectively and
seamlessly with a point-and-click
mechanism but at the same time leave the
floor open for programmatic intervention
for further downstream analysis and
hence this platform has the capability
to cater a new entrant in the
bioinformatics domain or an experienced
user alive now I would request Nesta to
predict for one who is in research
interned with us to give you our tour of
our server platform and his capabilities
Shivaji others as patty mentioned there
are various sections available on the D
bio info platform the first section is
the next-generation sequencing the
platform has made high throughput data
analysis easy through its
point-and-click interface although we
don't need to worry much about the
coding going on in the background many
of the algorithms generate an R script
which can be used for downstream
analysis the NGO section also covers the
areas namely transcriptomics under which
you can find pipelines for our ADC
transcript of deconvolution
de novo transcriptome assembly RNA
editing mutations annotation single-cell
transcriptome and many more under the
broad heading of genomics and
epigenetics you can find cheap
sequencing by self at DNA methylation
nutrition variation etc another area is
DNA or RNA under which you can find
microbiota 16s rRNA sequencing and many
other algorithms among the new medians
algorithms available in a simple Arabic
pipeline many of them has been
indigenously developed at Thorpe urban
home at its center namely for
pre-processing added to faster
PCR clean GTF adjust for data simulation
simulate simulate are for exon detection
as exxon for the purpose of mapping BS
KLB GPU and its two variants GPU i ng
beauty first presentation we have
purpose bring as many near Venus Mars
Venus and many other algorithms now on
my screen you can see how some artistic
pipeline interface looks like
let's now dig deeper and see how an
artistic pipeline works so this is the
front page of server dotty bio info
platform under the section of NGS data
you can find transcriptomics and if you
see under transcript or makes the first
option is an RNA seek pipeline the
artistic pipeline uses data of breast
cancer cell line as its input which are
in fast queue format here as you can see
in the input files drop down the input
files have already been uploaded
securely in the server and the s
handling now needs to be uploaded in the
pipeline we just have to click on OK and
you can see the start has been done
after we click on start we can see there
are various buttons present here which
are highlighted with the yellow
highlight this shows that which are the
algorithms which can which you can
follow to process your RNA sequencing
this is an exclusive artificial
intelligence guided platform which is
available in key bio info platform once
the data is uploaded we can now proceed
in the next part which is pre-processing
for data pre-processing algorithms like
chiba mattock and PCR clean can be use
trim ematic is an algorithm which
removes the adapter fragments from the
cDNA for sequencing as you can see there
is an educational pop which
click on the button Vaness geomatic and
also there's an Associated publication
which you can click to read and learn
more about this algorithm
after you click up ok you can see the PC
admin has been highlighted ECL clean is
used to remove the over duplicated PCR
replicates from your input data also as
mentioned before there's an educational
pop up which can tell you more about how
this algorithm works after you click on
ok the next thing which you need to do
is snapping your data against a
reference genome for that purpose you
can use hiset - it is an algorithm which
maps your data sequences against a
reference genome which you have a select
when you run your pipeline namely human
Homo sapiens GH 38 a rep adopts test
arianna human mouse concatenated and
anymore was it click OK the next button
which is highlighted is complains
cufflinks is an algorithm which is used
for isoform construction you need to
click on the button you know it named s
cufflinks and click on OK after you
click on cufflinks you have to click one
cup of merge cuff much is an algorithm
which is used to merge all the isoforms
together after we have done this part
the next row of which we need to do in
the pipeline is mapping our input data
against transcriptome for doing this we
use a very famous algorithm known as boh
type to G there's an educational pop-up
and an associated publication which you
can read to get more insight on this
algorithm after mapping against
transcriptome is done we need to
quantify our input data for
quantification we use an algorithm known
as our SVM expression table which uses e
and algorithm and you can adjust the
quantified data into three categories
namely rpkm
reads per kilo best million fpkm
Louis million and TPM transcripts per
million after you have clicked okay
there's a section which is known as
differential expression differential
expression offers a various kinds of
algorithms namely edge our comfort if DC
and ec2 for this particular pipeline we
are using the EC to what analyzing the
differentially expressed genes as you
can see by this graph which is there in
the pop-up and once we have done this we
can see that only n has been highlighted
so that means that we have successfully
created our pipeline now and we just
have to click on end and click OK
after we have clicked on end we can see
that our pipeline has been joined with a
dotted arrow it shows the pathway of our
pipeline once this pipeline completes
its running he will give the output
files which we can download from here as
you can see there is a long list of
output files out of which if you follow
the name there's expression isoforms
fpkm which gives the quantified isoforms
there's expression genes which gives you
the 25 genes in fpkm then there's te
seek to earn files which gives you the
differentially expressed genes so you
can click on any of these names of the
output files download them and then take
your analysis further moving on the next
area of analysis is data integration and
modeling which includes hydrology data
Association and multi-omics and data
mining which comprises of machine
learning algorithms mainly supervisor
analysis unsupervised analysis and many
more now I would like to give the stage
to a part of the wall who is a research
intern at Pine bio apart the stage is
all yours
Hank you should retreat thank you Pithom
thank you for the be a brief description
of the platform and the demo of the
pipeline so as you all can see
that how easy is it to perform such a
complex analysis of RNA seek pipeline
and the differential gene analysis using
the T by n foot platform but there is
more that you can do with the help of
the platform such as biology experiments
data Association using the multi omics
integration genome-wide Association and
as briefly described I should be gene
you can also perform data mining using
multiple machine learning algorithms
briefly described as supervised and
unsupervised analysis so let's get a
dive into that and give you a demo of
what this supervised and unsupervised
section looks like so again we will go
to the platform and here you can see we
have divided the data mining section
into supervised and unsupervised
analysis so the unsupervised and
supervised analysis covers the following
tools in the unsupervised section you
can find PCA P clustering edge+ k-means
now you can see that there is pca
we see our library and so let's try to
run a pipeline that should which is just
read run with the RSC m table or the
expression for file date filter data so
it just click on upload files and select
a file of our esteem expression let's
use the 7000 with the 15 genes so we
have now uploaded our data click
continue start and you get a pop-up
again which will describe what della
rhythm you are using and how it is
working and you can find more or on the
educational background of it here so you
can set the parameters of this plot such
as the number of pieces that you want to
plot we want to scale your data yes we
want to do that centralization
transposing your data click on yes and
done that's it so once you are done give
up I give you a pipe and a good name
please see a demo and just save it the
platform is very user-friendly as you
can find your other pipelines under my
pipeline section you can see the
progress of your previous pipelines
you can delete your own pipelines or you
can run the analysis again you can
download the PDF of the outputs and even
the the backend summary of the platforms
pipeline that you ran so that you can
publish them in your research so I am
already done the pipeline before this
webinar so let's look into the results
of that the pipeline that comes with the
on our package that you can download and
these are the plots that you will get
once you run the any seek analysis so
since we had set three plots you can see
this one problem is clearly D markets
all the clusters this is another plot
and this is done so these are the plots
that we just ran using the same data
that should be G through created in the
RNA seek analysis pipeline but you can
do more with this you can download the
script from the platform and change
change the visualization as per your
demands and make it more beautiful using
the R script from the platform so all
the data that you will get from the
platform is readily available to publish
in your research journals as it's very
high quality in high definition images
and plots so the USP of our platform is
how powerful it is to integrate the
multi omics data you can integrate the
genomic data epigenetics data
transcriptomics data proteomics data and
all this is available under one section
called the multi omics Association the
cutting-edge tools such as high
clustering SNF tools p class and by
class all of these tools are currently
being used to perform the multi AMEX
research and all of that can be just one
click away so to learn all about this
moneth will be describing you more on
that so all yours much before I jump
into the into my presentation I would
just like to go back and summarize
thanks for you here so
what we have shown so far here in very I
think we did it it like release a super
speed but one of the reasons is to make
you all understand that it's a
point-and-click based system so
point-and-click based system what does
it give us so we have different sort of
data types we have we are looking at NGS
data we are looking at mass spectra so
mass spectroscopy data we are looking at
structural biology data and then we are
integrating a lot of data so we have
specialized projects in biology where we
have collaborated with universities and
developed complicated pipelines which
integrated different sort of omics data
so in transcriptomics we showed you a
demonstration of RNA seek pipeline where
the cell line is cancer breast cell can
breast cancer cell line data and then
after you know doing the looking at the
rod data
you pre-process the data then from
pre-processing you can are some table
and then you look at the differential
gene expression so after doing all that
you what you're trying to find out is
number of genes that are differentially
expressed in one condition than the
other so we have a we are looking for a
cluster of genes that might be you know
differentially expressed in breast
cancer and versus a normal cell so after
that we looked into the PCA what is PC
PC is something which which does a which
does dimensionality reduction so what
does dimensionality reduction we are
looking at a very big data so as you see
here we have uploaded just and small as
we will find but the svl file has a link
to all the data all the FRU data which
are big insights so we are uploading a
lot of big data here and then we are
trying to see what is what meaning we
can get out of that big data so to
understand that we are doing we are
using different type of a different sort
of you know algorithms that can give us
meaning out of that or maybe we can
visualize that data which is also
Challenge two you know when you have
data data of size of GPS and mb/s it's
really difficult to plot them in a excel
sheet and understand the meaning out of
it so we are trying to reduce the data
so that we can get the meaningful data
so what we did in PCA is we try to
cluster them into different groups and
see whether you know we can classify
them based on the the same based on
their types their subtypes so we have we
have we have these different subtypes in
breast cancer which we trying to
classify so this these sort of
techniques are very powerful in
understanding multiple applications in
bioinformatics may that be make it it is
helpful in patient stratification where
we are trying to give a where we are
trying to segregate patients into two
different groups we are also looking at
you know biomarkers we are also looking
at personalized medicine so these are
some of the real-time application of of
using technology such as this one of the
another factor that one of the another
thing as a by informatician or as a
biologist that gives me a leverage by
using this platform is you know the ease
of access so I do agree that sometimes
people feel like you know building their
own pipelines and doing their own
analysis for everything but it does help
to have a have a you know platform like
this where you can quickly input your
data and look for a pattern where it is
there or not once you see that and once
you can repeat these sort of experiments
with different different kind of
conditions you will definitely have a
better scientific better scientific
output out of it because you're looking
at patterns at at a very ease by
point-and-click and you're using
different type of data types and as a
parrot he said the one of the biggest
USP is is the data mining aspect of
things where we are looking at data
mining and data Association we are not
only we are not there we are not not
only looking at you know signal type of
omics data but we are integrating the
kind of omics data so these these sort
of data where where we are talking about
you know transcription of where we are
looking at the transcription level where
we are looking at the you know mutation
variants where we are looking at the
epigenetic changes so overall an
integration of this give a holistic
picture of what is going on and what is
happening so that we can derive a
solution strategy so the platform
enables us all of us to do that very
easily but as as many of us like many of
us come from different backgrounds we do
need to understand these data types so
how we can understand these data store
data types we have an educational
platform that I'm going to talk about in
the next section so I hope you have a
cuff of overview of what what are the
capabilities obviously going into detail
of one of each of these pipelines is
very difficult as you see these are very
complicated pipelines one on each of the
pipeline's have multiple algorithms so
we do have courses for everyone to
understand about this about this about
our platform about this analysis and we
start we start from basic so let's go
down to the educational platform and
talk about and let me talk about the
courses that we have so to understand
all of this and a part of a part of a
part of the analysis that we have shown
we have a course on introduction to
bioinformatics we have a course on
genomics a different type of mutation
where we are talking about different
type of mutational variants and we are
looking at the genome and looking at the
changes from the reference genome and
things like that
we have transcriptomics we are looking
at the difference in gene expression
from one state to another then we are
looking at the epigenetic changes then
we also look into where we have also
pipelines and courses on on analysis of
metagenomics data we are looking at
microbiome and then then then a
technique to you know get meaning out of
it so machine learning so we have these
courses which are readily available in
our platform
and that can be accessed using this
website so why don't we go and see the
platform itself in a demonstration here
so we saw there our server platform now
we will look into the educational
platform and what it offers so the
educational T - bio dot info platform
has number of courses so these courses
like transcript are like introduction to
by informatics I said this is how it
looks so once you start taking this
course which is a free course this is
absolutely free for everyone so once you
if you if you can see the curriculum
this is a curriculum this is a course
built for to make everyone understand as
you see there are like high number of
ratings the ratings are really good
because the course is billed in a in a
in a way that it makes even understand
what is the importance of data-driven
discovery what is the importance of you
know research in health care what is how
things are changing in molecular
diagnostic treatment development using
this high-throughput data so the
application of by informatics in
agriculture environmental sciences
defences and everything has been covered
in introduction to bioinformatics course
it's a great boost I would recommend
every one of you to take this course and
another course that I would like to
demonstrate here today is
transcriptomics one the things that we
covered the pipeline that we did
everything is described in a logical
steps here one by one we have
interactive videos we have forum where
you can post your questions and where we
we have personalized you notice two
things we we talk to participants we
talk to our students and we give them a
thorough knowledge of what is happening
and how we can you can do the analysis
on your own so it's more like an
enabling thing more like a collaboration
rather than a service so we would this
is how it works in our educational
platform so other than the core other
than the courses we have specialization
tracks like oncology neurology which
many of them are coming up which we are
working on and then we have special
nice projects so let me go back to my
presentation so yes you can check this
URL go to this URL and check the check
out I'll check our educational website
so now we do have a lot of projects so
how do we conceptualize the projects so
what we actually do is we we take
publications that has high impact that
has high impact on the society that high
has importance in the data types that
have been explained here this those data
types have been used and shown that the
the analysis has has a meaning out of it
so we take take those publications those
are important and have these these sort
of analysis that we want to showcase
that we want people to learn so we take
the data out of that we look at the
methods we replicate it using our own
server and then we build a project out
of it which these projects have been
build and then you can build your own
projects using using the same
methodology or by using your same in
using your ideas so the projects are the
data types we are talking about here we
have different type of data we have
different type of projects so the
project's encompasses from biotechnology
you know modeling precision treatment
for breast cancer so we are take take or
we are talking about 63 cell lines here
so these are high throughput data that
we have been extracting that we are
extracted from these publications so
there is projects on biology there is
projects on agriculture there is prod
there are projects on cancer the
different type of cancer immune response
immunology biomarkers so we have these
specialized set of projects for anyone
on everyone to take so that they
understand the methodology and and they
understand how these projects have been
conceptualized and they can be used for
our research so the users can go and
check check these projects in origin and
you can design in the end of it when you
are capable when you understand the data
Tikes when you understand the process
then you're in a hundred when you
understand the technology then you can
design your own project as well so as I
as I showcased you the platform how the
platform is actually helping us help how
a platform is helping the user to you
know see his progress so what it gives
as a user as a participant as a student
what I'm getting out of the educational
platform so I am finishing lot of
courses on different type of multihoming
analysis out of which I am learning a
lot and there is a hands-on practice
with every course with every course I am
doing a lot of hands-on practice which
is recommended in that post and I'm
using the TBN for platform to understand
the data types to understand the process
to understand the algorithms and the and
the semantic way of things and then out
of it I am getting a certificate so I'm
earning a certificate or an
international certificate I'm seeing my
progress I'm looking at my year the
number of points that I'm scoring which
is based on the usage of the platform
usage of the pipeline's
so I am I've been able to evaluate
myself how well I'm am i doing so that's
a that's a platform cap capability which
yes which it gives to every user so
Suraj it as you said has joined us for
almost two months now and has finished
and have learned so much in so much
short of a short time in in my entire
carrier I have not seen something like
this when this platform which which this
platform gives is to you know ease
easily understand things and at a rapid
pace a rapid pace so these are some of
the us piece for the platform for the
educational side similarly and like with
all these programs going on we have been
getting like lot of good reviews from
very reputed people all around the globe
who are taking our different who are
taking different programs that they are
you know carrying on so I'll go back to
the programs next but we have been
getting a lot of good reviews we are
getting a lot of good
bags just which is also helping us
improve in a way that people are also
suggesting what it is lacking what we
can do more so it's been a very
interesting experience
so the
talking of some of the programs that are
ongoing right now is it this is an
example of specialization track
so by informatics for precision oncology
so we are here we have been talking
about precision oncology specifically
cancer we are dealing with liver cancer
and breast cancer data so we are looking
through the eyes of genomic variations
through transcriptomics analysis through
machine learning and then a project to
understand how by informatics is helping
in precision oncology this is a very
important or this is a very much
practiced is a practiced methodology
that has been going on in us and it's
been now in practice everywhere so it's
it's it holds a very very much
importance in what we are learning out
of this program so many of the people
have
out of this a ban from an expert
precision oncology program similarly we
have these specialization special track
programs like in a year we we try to do
make people understand about the
genomics data about the meta genomics
data about the transcriptomics data and
other data types so this is another
program which has which is a three
months program this has been carried out
by by despina who is in Israel who is in
Greece and she's an expert in genomics
she's in our team so we have a good set
of people who are trying to tell about
the different data types out there and
how to use the platform and how to
understand this data and make a good
project or a good proposal out of it so
in India in India we have started this
with MIT University Kolkata where we
have started with a program called
introduction to by informatics this this
is not an specialization track as as I
was showing before this is more like an
overview of things we are discussing
about transcriptomics genomics
metagenomics machine learning then a
project so it will have an application
of everything an overview of everything
and then application of different
domains where people will be able to do
a team project with their faculty in
Amity University Kolkata in similarly we
have collaborated with sustainability'
University for data science or for
biologists a similar program where we
are trying to tell people tell the
people from the University of the same
from cisterna Medical University and
people who work who can who will be able
to take this course online all of these
courses that you are offering the best
part is that you can take them online
you can take them from anywhere me we do
have workshops on-site workshops that
will be also telecasted online so the
whole whole course is available online
so that it can be availed by anyone who
is sitting anywhere
similarly we
another collaboration with pine biotech
and IgE this will be a this will start
somewhere in in September this is a
program that I would recommend people
who have not joined our programs yet to
come and join and understand what we are
trying to tell here recently we joined
bio clues because we believe that it's a
great organization that promotes project
based bioinformatics education and
brings together researchers with a
diverse background that are already
active in the bioinformatics space so we
would like to continue and explore how
we can work together and how we can
develop new programs and address
important topics that are both important
for the students but also important for
the faculty to leverage bioinformatics
tools more effectively any participant
who would like to unmute themselves and
give a brief description about the work
or themselves and how any comments that
they would have for this platform of
ours so it was nice so all the tools I
saw in the pipeline but one question was
there they in the same pipeline for the
same analysis type there are several
foods there right so just wanted to ask
that which one to prefer like if someone
wants to like most most precise results
out of their analysis so which tool will
prefer just want to ask because I'm
curious because of this tool issue
because in galaxy I was when I was new
so I was using this galaxy platform so
there are some of the foods like top hat
and this coupling tools are they're
mentioned as deprecated tool so that's
why this question is there in my mind
now
as you saw there are some preferred
suggestions and they are going to be in
the tutorials that we provide there are
more in-depth explanations about the
process of selecting and combining those
tools together and ultimately designing
the pipeline that is most fit to get the
answer that you're looking for some of
the tools like you mentioned are
regularly updated but they you can show
the the pipeline there but you can see
if you scroll down you can see for
example some of the steps are going to
be faster for processing some of the
steps one question I have
can I get any is there any visualization
course like visualization of biological
data or answers for them visualization
for the data like PCA plot you are
showing though I was asking about the
clusters there yeah we are going to be
posting a series of machine learning
biostatistics data visualization and
coding so that you can start from the
heavy pipeline and ultimately get a
biologically interpretable result but
also be able to add more layers of
information to your visualization so
that is pending but it's coming soon we
believe that we will have it in
September and we'll make sure to share
that with you as well our training
programs are designed to first introduce
the conceptual understanding so that we
understand what is PCA how does that
help us understand data we also have
different review of these tools like
clustering and classification tools
all of that is already available in
transcriptomics 3 and we have a whole
course on machine learning for
biomedical data that you can already
start looking at but more in depth
visualization tools and more custom
visualization tools we believe that
we'll be ready by September and we'll
let everybody know that it's launched
thank you everyone for attending
yeah these are the email addresses that
you can reach out to you can reach out
to any of us and we'll be able to
address those questions that we
discussed today - towards platform and
forces